[Música]
cada cuatro años los mejores panaderos
de los cinco continentes se enfrentan
durante la copa del mundo de panadería
36 países están representados
cada equipo debe realizar diferentes
tipos de panes repostería fina así como
una obra de arte
[Música]
5 y 10 de la mañana inicio de una
jornada maratónica los candidatos
cuentan con 8 horas para sorprender al
jurado
desde 2008 francia no ha ganado el
título supremo el colmo fan el país sin
la baguette y una presión adicional
sobre los hombros de los tres panaderos
tricolores
porque el saber hacer francés hoy en día
es practicado en todo el mundo
ya yo en una estación en vecina el chico
chino es entrenado por un paradero de el
wak
a los chinos les encanta una buena
baguette a los crujientes entonces les
inculcamos las buenas técnicas buenos
métodos con las buenas recetas luego son
capaces de reproducir casi idénticamente
lo que elegimos
el equipo chino espera subir al podio
pero su participación en el concurso ya
es un éxito en sí si no ganamos no es
grave porque durante el concurso
aprendemos muchas cosas solo mira la
competencia está en su punto más intenso
desde hace varias horas los fans
franceses por fin llegan
le tienen fe al equipo francés sí por lo
menos el podio
por su lado close casado está
concentrado en su obra de arte su
escultura de poner en escena un deporte
los tricolores eligieron el ciclismo
eslabón por eslabón monta la cadena de
pasta dura de su bicicleta
[Música]
de ahora o por su parte está a cargo de
la repostería fina
trabaja bajo la mirada atenta de los
siete jueces del concurso
por el momento los productos que han
salido son muy bellos en cuanto al tema
artístico tengo un poco de miedo estamos
a una hora y media antes del final no he
empezado a montar sus piezas
el lugar está vacío dos minutos avanzan
la presión aumenta para cloud cuando su
instalación empieza a finalmente se
quedan tan sólo 45 minutos
[Aplausos]
[Música]
es un poco apretado pero lo logrará
sobre la hora
[Aplausos]
poco a poco la pieza artística toma
forma el ensamblaje es la fase más
delicada
piñón marco manubrio cable de freno todo
está hecho de pasta son muy frágiles y
se pueden romper en cualquier momento
y hay que avanzar lentamente no
desconcentrarse
estamos a 10 minutos del final
todo el equipo francés trabaja
rápidamente para terminar la obra de
claude aún falta rellenar la obra
maestra con 60 repostería fina saladas y
sándwiches
[Aplausos]
todo debe haber sido limpiado porque la
higiene y la presentación hacia en parte
de las escalas de clasificación del
jurado
[Aplausos]
el equipo francés termina sobre el ahora
sobre la hora mucha presión
nos atrasamos tuvimos problemas
mecánicos agua por todas partes un horno
no vaporizada
entonces nos atrasamos y unas horas
pasaban y dudaba de que lo lograrán
no podíamos fracasar hemos estado
trabajando durante tres años
permitieron la obra
[Aplausos]
la perseverancia de los franceses es
recompensada por el anuncio de los
resultados
suben al tercer escalón del ángulo
a ver
taiwán consigue la medalla de plata el
título se lo lleva corea del sur la
escultura fue la que sedujo a los
jurados este país colecciona desde hace
decenios las medallas de oro olímpico
del tiro con arco la panadería se volvió
su nuevo objetivo frente a esta nueva
competencia francia tendrá que mejorar
para llevarse en la copa mundo durante
los próximos años
[Música]
y